we moved to Memphis now with a look at
Lisa Marie Presley's final resting place
at Graceland you're the only people that
can bring me out of my house
today ET confirmed Elvis's only daughter
has been laid to rest next to her son
Ben at the Graceland meditation Garden
yesterday it was ConEd off and covered
with tarps as the Graceland website
noted following the 9 A.M memorial
service all fans may join a procession
to the meditation Garden where Lisa
Marie and her family have been laid to
rest family is expected to attend
Sunday's public Memorial including Lisa
Marie's three daughters who will inherit
Elvis's estate what is it like for them
when they go there
um you know they love it there and love
their family they love their family Lisa
Marie passed away last Thursday after
suffering Cardiac Arrest meanwhile
Leslie Jordan's cause of death has just
been revealed the LA coroner says the 67
year old died from Sudden cardiac
dysfunction while driving in Hollywood
last October
also in California news on the intense
search for missing actor Julian Sands
now into day six
audiences are always ready for good
films famous for his film roles in a
room with a view and leaving Las Vegas
Julian hasn't been seen since Friday
morning when he left his La home for a
mountain hike 50 miles away in Stormy
Weather authorities finding the 65 year
old's car in the parking lot deserted
since his disappearance his wife did
report him missing the conditions are
too dangerous in fact even some of the
more experienced hikers are getting
themselves into trouble up there
sheriffs tell ET due to the risk of
avalanche ground Crews were pulled off
the mountain on Saturday we continue to
search by helicopter and drones and
we'll schedule another ground search
when the weather improves E.T met Julian
when he was Jody Foster's Oscar date in
1989. he's known to be an expert hiker
and his three adult children have joined
the search
[Music]